The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right
welcome back, everyone.
I can't wait to hear about
your projects and trips.
So today you guys are
going to do presentations.
Then we're going to go
through a really quick review
of the design process,
which is appropriate,
because we have a really quick
design process to go through.
And then you guys
will do probably
no brainstorming--
maybe a little,
but then doing Pugh
charts to figure out
what projects make sense for the
class to work on the semester.
And then part of
that will be you're
going to do micro presentations
at the end of the class
that you'll prep during
class so that you guys can
select what projects you're
going to work on tonight.
Are there any questions or
anything to note while you--
before we get started?
OK.
And so ideally, we'll do
GrupoFenix, first, and then
ASAPROSAR, and then AsoFenix.
OK, so do you guys
want to start?
AUDIENCE: So hi, everyone.
For those of you who
don't know, [INAUDIBLE]..
We're GrupoFenix.
We traveled to
Sabana Grande, which
is 20 minutes south
of Ocotal, which
is one of the bigger cities in
Nicaragua, for spring break.
And we were there for five, six
days, and we had a lot of fun.
So the first thing
I'll talk about--
this is our group.
I'll talk about our group.
AUDIENCE: That's Jorge.
AUDIENCE: And Jorge--
I guess we should
introduce ourselves.
I'm Jessica.
AUDIENCE: I'm Vivian.
AUDIENCE: Liz--
AUDIENCE: Kurt--
AUDIENCE: Sid--
AUDIENCE: Juan--
AUDIENCE: Beautiful.
And this is Jorge.
He is the shop manager field--
onsite field manager guy.
He's the go-to guy.
Basically, you hear
his name over 300 times
in an hour being shouted.
Jorge, get us this.
Jorge, get us that--
so really handy guy.
Were we able to give
him a D-Lab [INAUDIBLE]??
No-- so next time.
So we're not going to
talk about this first.
We're going to talk about
the charcoal burn first.
So when we got
there, the itinerary
was to do a lot
of charcoal burns,
because that was one
of our projects--
possible projects to work on.
And there's a lot of
opportunity there,
because when we got
there on Monday,
we had our first burn with
them, and they showed us
the briquettes
that they had been
able to make from
their Friday burn.
And this is what came out of it.
And as you see it
from-- if you remember
from our briquette making--
it's really great, especially
when you compare it to the
blackness of this darker
charcoal, which is
a successful burn
and a successful briquette
made while we were there.
So this is what
we made with them.
This is what they had made the
Friday before we got there.
And there was improvement-- yay.
In this picture, you
see all the white smoke,
which is basically the water
vapor from the barrel burning.
And it's because, when
they used the Friday--
this was used in
the same biomass
that they used Friday,
which is this corn stock.
And this corn stock
apparently wasn't dry enough.
It seemed like it
was dry enough,
but only when we
were burning it did
we see that it wasn't actually
dry enough for the briquettes.
At the end of our
week there, we were
able to make over 150
briquettes from the two burns.
And so we yielded
150 briquettes.
Before they were only
making six to seven
of these briquettes
for each charcoal burn.
And they were looking
at those frantically,
because when we got
there, they already
expressed that they did have
a big interest in charcoal
making, because
they're starting--
this is a solar center, and
on the other side of the field
is the restaurant that they're
going to start operating.
And one of the fuels
that they want to use
is charcoal briquettes to
cook in the restaurant.
So they wanted to make this
economically feasible and ready
to sell for the people
of Sabana Grande,
possibly to resell it to Ocotal.
And so we were able to get
a better yield for them.
Some quick lessons learned--
so a little bit of the history--
Amy came in after Judy.
Judy is a random
service volunteer
that came to the
women of Totogalpa,
to the Solar Women of
Totogalpa, and taught them
how to do the charcoal burns.
But apparently she taught them
completely wrong, because she--
the timing on covering the--
on sealing the barrel,
like we all know, was off.
And so because of
that, they were only
yielding six to seven, and
it was burning too much,
so it was getting ashy.
She didn't teach
them little checks.
So what we did--
I'm sorry-- what we did is
that Kurt and I sat down
with two charcoal
captains, we called them.
Two of the women were
made charcoal captains,
because Kurt and I
briefed them extensively
for like a four-hour
period and instructed them
on what the instructions
meant, the diagrammed ones
that we have in Spanish.
And so we went over
the translations,
because the Spanish that it
was translated into sometimes
was a little different
in Nicaraguan,
so we did that
translation so that they
could understand it better.
And then we made
them in charge of--
as captains, they
chose to other women,
and that-- those four women
were the charcoal committee.
So these two women,
the captains,
instructed the other two
women on the process.
So now it's a little bit
more of an internal thing.
You also learn better
when you teach, right?
And so by the time that
we got there on Thursday,
we regrouped.
And on Thursday we did the
charcoal burn in the morning,
with all four of them
just leading the way.
They would say every step of
the process before they did it,
and it showed that they
really picked up on it.
And by the afternoon, they
did another burn basically
completely by themselves.
The successful key
points that they really--
that really showed us that they
knew what they were talking
about was when we would ask
them in the middle of it all,
just to check, how do
you know if it's good--
if it's a good burn?
And they would say, oh,
you got to crack it open,
and the heart has to be black.
And I would say, OK.
How do if the
biomass is too wet?
They would say,
oh, because you'd
have a lot of white
smoke, and that's bad.
And I'm like, so what's
the yellow smoke then?
And then they'd say, oh,
those are the contaminants.
And I'm like, contaminants?
But that's what
the wood has when
you're cooking with it, right?
And they go, no, it's
different, because--
and then they would be able to
explain all the process and all
the logic, and really
get to the why of things.
Kurt--
AUDIENCE: Cool.
For the Thursday burns
that Jess described,
we went out to the
fields and collected
biomass that had been
sitting there for a month.
So it was way drier.
And so this prompted us to think
about a possible project for us
to work on--
at least something
to think about,
which is whether to bring
the biomass into the center
and burn it there or figure
out some way of being
able to do the
burns at the fields
where all this dry biomass is.
And because Sabana Grande's
quite a large area,
we thought maybe that
could be something
that we could think about,
particularly from the cost
perspective, which Liz is going
to talk about in a little bit.
But other things that
we're looking at as far
as possible projects are
also this solar dryer
for briquettes,
because we discovered,
in interviewing the women,
that the biggest problem they
had with the process was having
to air dry these briquettes
for three to four days outside.
And they didn't want to
take them outside each day
and then have to
bring them back in,
and then be worried
always about the rain.
So they work on these--
their primary work is
on the solar ovens,
but they also do solar dryers.
So we experimented a little
bit with using these,
and we think that one
project we could work on
is a solar dryer specifically
for charcoal briquettes
so they can start making
these really quickly as--
almost like a
factory so that they
can supply them to
their restaurant
and achieve scale there.
And so this shows some
more of the process.
This is the new biomass that we
brought in that was way dryer.
This is our second burn.
And this was the
briquette making process.
So one other thing
that we thought
could be a potential
project is experimenting
with the like cornstarch
versus yuca versus using banana
starch, because they have--
they can just by cornstarch
there pretty cheaply, and
it's much easier for them
to do that than have to grind
up this yuca for binder.
So those are basically
the range of projects
that we're thinking about
right now, as far as charcoal.
And if you want to talk a little
bit about the cost study now--
AUDIENCE: So we
also, really quickly,
did cost study so that we
could ensure that teaching them
charcoal was actually useful,
because they basically wanted
to get paid 10 cordoba an hour--
which is like $0.50 an hour--
and work seven-hour days.
And so based on those
numbers and roughly
how many burns we thought
they could do in one day,
if they just did like
a bunch of burns in one
day and just had a few
going at a time maybe,
we thought that they
would be able to sell it
for slightly cheaper than you
could buy it in Ocotal, which
was a 20-minute bus ride away,
so that it could actually
be a feasible option.
And they also really
wanted to use this charcoal
in their restaurant.
So hopefully, if they
really get into this
and they get a lot better
at it, then they'll
be able to actually
use charcoal,
and it'll be economically viable
as well as a clean alternative.
I'm also going to talk
about solar ovens, which
I think-- here we go.
This is their solar
oven that they
have all over the solar center.
It's sort of the
symbol of solar woman
that we were working with,
because it's something
that they build.
They paint them
this bright color.
They all work a lot of
hours in the solar center,
and then when they build
up a certain number
of hundreds of hours, they
can buy one for themselves.
So some of the women
have them at home.
And they can use
them to make things
like cookies, which you see
here, which they can't actually
make in--
on a wood fire.
So a lot of the women
really enjoy them.
And while they're not really
a very economically viable
option, they're a way of
bringing the women together,
which we thought was
really interesting.
There was a Cornell
group they're
working on these solar ovens to
try to improve their insulation
and other smaller parts
while we were there,
so we worked a lot with them.
And they actually built a
new oven with fiberglass
insulation while we
were there, so we
got to see how
they were built. We
feel as if there's
not too much more
that we can add to that
project, as opposed
to the many other
projects that are there,
so really the only projects
that we think we should possibly
pursue with regards
to the solar cookers
was the solar dryer
for the charcoal.
And then that was
the final charcoal
that was supposed to be before.
AUDIENCE: So
[INAUDIBLE] so right
now they make these
panels by hand.
The way it works is that
the group GrupoFenix gets
all of the extra small
panels from the US,
and they buy boxes of the panels
that don't pass the test here
in the US.
And for about 500 of the
small panels, it's about $500.
So it's about $1 a cell--
sorry-- a cell--
so about $1 a cell.
The problem is that, out of
the 500 cells that they get,
there's about 100 to 200
broken, depending on the box.
So it's more than that.
And so this is a really
intensive project--
process of making the
cells-- the panels.
I'm just going to go
over it really quick.
Oh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
setup, like set everything up.
AUDIENCE: You want to
just talk on this slide,
or was there another slide?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's the next one.
OK.
Yeah, so first they
connect them all
and they call them
chains, solar cell chains.
They solder everything by hand,
and they test every single cell
by hand and every chain by hand.
Then they move these changes
independently to this paper.
And then, after they place
each chain independently,
they then add liquid silicon
all over the panels by hand.
And they have to make sure
that it's evenly spread, one,
and there are no air bubbles.
And then they get
the glass, and they
have to put it evenly on top.
And then, by hand they try to
squish out all the air bubbles
that are still in there.
Then they add foam
and add batteries.
And this is kind of
a annoying process,
because they have to put
each battery at the same--
two batteries at
the same time so it
will have even pressure
across the cells.
And they leave it
there for 24 hours so
that the last air
bubbles can escape,
and so that it can be
completely flat and even.
So there's obviously
a lot of improvement.
It takes about 24 hours to make
one of the large solar cell--
solar panels.
And they produce
about 220 watts.
So some of the [INAUDIBLE]
we were thinking about were--
he mentioned, instead of
having to place the batteries
to heavier pressure,
Maybe just an even way
that you can just pull down,
and it holds on the pressure.
We were also thinking about
having some type of vacuum pump
or vacuum chamber
that just removes
all the air bubbles so you
don't have to do it by hand.
Oh, there's also another thing.
They're thinking about using
ethyl vinyl acetate, instead of
the liquid silicon, to cover
and insulate the solar cells.
The problem with the EVA is
that it has to be heated heated,
and then it has-- and then
there's also air bubbles,
even if it does heat up.
So another possible
project is a way
to heat it maybe using the solar
ovens, which they say they did,
or maybe just--
maybe another way.
That could be another
possible project.
OK.
So those are the
large solar panels,
which they use for
their homes and they
using the power the restaurant,
and they're also using
to power the solar center.
Then they're trying to make
the small solar cell phone
chargers, which
you saw last time.
And they're trying to
basically model to this.
This is worth $10 in Ocotal,
and it's made in China.
The great thing about it
is that it actually comes
with a cell phone battery.
It fits most Nokia cell phones.
And what you see
on the right side
is a charger as well as a lamp.
So not only can you
charge your cell phone--
you can use-- also use the
battery to power up a light.
So that would be
the ideal project.
So yeah, that would
be an ideal project.
Currently, what they're working
on is just the solar cells.
And because they need
a smaller voltage,
and they don't really have
much access to capacitors
or resistors, they cut--
go back to-- yeah--
they cut every cell by hand
using this-- using a dremel.
So that's another cause, and
another way to cut the cells,
instead of having to do it by
hand, would be another project.
What I have here is a little
old battery cell phone charger.
So you basically put
your battery here,
and then you move
around, depending
on where your battery is, and
you can charge your cell phone.
You can pass it around
if you want to see it.
And so we were thinking
of installing that
to the solar panel so you could
charge any type of battery,
not just Nokia, ideally.
What else?
AUDIENCE: A main issue with that
is also the cost, because we
were having a lot of
trouble figuring out
how you would actually--
using their current system,
their prices would be a lot
higher than the China-made one--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --which is hard.
Yeah, right now the
costs are really
the biggest issue, the fact that
each solar cell is about $1.
Then the silicon-- they use
about 600 grams of the liquid
silicon right now, and that's--
I forget the number.
It's all in my head, but I think
it's about $100 for 5 gallons.
And just everything adds up.
The labor, I think, is
the most intensive part.
They really use about 12 actual
hours, 24 hours with the drying
included.
The glass is
relatively expensive,
and then there's the
aluminum on the side.
There's also the solar--
the tape, that they
have to do it by hand--
which is not really tape.
It's the little aluminum strips.
So that could even
be another project.
Maybe have a aluminum tape.
That way, you can use tape,
instead of having to solder on.
That could be another
great project.
So we're going to
keep talk-- oh,
and [? Mario. ?] There are
two people that really make
the solar cells right now, which
is the guy in the top left,
which is [? Mario. ?] And then
there's another [? Mario, ?]
which is like little [? Mario ?]
and big [? Mario-- ?]
who's the only male member of
the cooperative of the Solar
Women of Totogalpa.
Yep.
That's about it.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
So once we spent a
couple of days there,
we realized that a
lot of the center
is focused specifically
towards 20 women who
are part of the cooperative.
And so again, wondering, if
we did design a project based
on what we learned
at the center,
would it only benefit
those 20 people,
or would it help the
surrounding area in general?
And so this is
actually the only slide
that we have for that
part, but basically,
what we decided to do
is me and [? Kwan ?]
walked a couple of kilometers
down into another district
called Santa Domingo.
And this is the
road we walked on.
And so Santa Domingo does
not have great electricity,
so they're basically cut
off from any conventional
electrical appliances.
And so we wanted to
go there and ask them
what their involvement
with the center
was, if they had considered
other options for solar,
or wind, or whatever.
And so we asked them
a bunch of questions.
So the first thing
we asked them was
if they'd heard of charcoal.
And we interviewed 10 families,
and none of them used charcoal.
Three of the
families hadn't even
heard of carbon,
which is what-- yeah.
So they didn't know what it was.
We then went on to ask them
what they did use to cook,
and they all said firewood.
We asked them where they
get the firewood from.
All of them get the firewood
from their surrounding
communities, but
there was actually
one woman who walked
3 kilometers every day
just to get firewood,
which we thought
was kind of unfortunate.
We also asked them
after that if they
do use some form of lighting
at night, and if so, what?
All the families we
interviewed did have
some kind of lamps at night.
Mostly they were diesel lamps.
We weren't sure exactly
how they worked,
but they all either used diesel
or ocote, which is pinewood,
or electric lamps,
which run on batteries.
So once they said that
they do use batteries,
we asked them what they
did use batteries for.
And it turned out that they
basically used batteries
for three things--
lighting, radios, and if
they're big 9-volt batteries,
then you could power
a cell phone charger.
So once we asked
them about that,
we also asked them about how
many cell phones they have,
or if they did have
any, per family.
And four out of nine of the
families we interviewed had
cell phones, but
the rest didn't.
And for the families that
did have cell phones,
we asked them how
they charge them,
because they weren't
near the grid.
So apparently, what
they do is they
walk to a house
which is in the--
which is in Sabana Grande
to charge their cell phones,
and are charged 5 to 10 cordoba
for each cycle of recharging.
Apart from that, we also
asked them if they had cycles.
This was just out of curiosity,
because we were wondering
if pedal power was any--
if it was viable.
And every family did
have at least one cycle.
Oh, yeah, so a
cell phone battery
charges for 5 to 10 cordoba,
and a 12-volt battery
charges for 30 cordoba.
That was pretty much it.
We just wanted to
get some perspective
on off-grid communities.
And yeah, that's pretty
much-- that's what--
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: You guys are supposed
to do a 10-minute presentation,
so if you can just go--
AUDIENCE: OK.
Real quick.
OK, so while Juan and Sid were
doing off-grid interviews,
Liz and I did some interviews
at the different homes
of the women, and
we also had a day
where we cooked
with the women, just
to gauge their
usage of charcoal,
whether they're using it
or not, and reasons why,
and just to really get
an insider's perspective.
So we found out that most people
aren't using the charcoal.
They prefer to cook
with wood over charcoal,
basically because they
can gather it for free.
They have to pay to
buy the charcoal.
They don't have to go
to Ocotal to buy it.
And they say tortillas are a
very big part of their diet.
They get up early every
morning, go to the [INAUDIBLE]
to grind the corn, go
through this process,
and they make tortillas
every single day.
So it's a very huge
part of their diet.
And they found that the
charcoal doesn't burn hot enough
to make the tortillas, so
they prefer using wood.
And also, on their
adobe stoves, you
can cook multiple
things at once, which
is also why they prefer wood.
So this was a good
inside look at why
they're not using charcoal.
And we also saw, when we were
cooking with one of the women,
that she kept on using
tinders from the wood fire--
from that wood fire and she's
dumping it into the charcoal
to try to light it.
She was having a really
hard time doing that.
And a very small side project is
just better charcoal education.
And I think it's going to
be really important to make
this charcoal affordable
so that they will see this
as an option over wood.
Another thing we surveyed
the families about
was their electricity usage.
And we noticed that most people,
if they had solar panels,
they were bought
using green hours.
And because these
families don't--
they don't want to pay the
extra amount for an inverter,
so other solar panels are used
for lighting in their homes.
Some families are lucky enough
to pay for-- to have enough
money to pay for
grid electricity,
which they use to
charge cell phones and--
some families have
TVs and radios.
Other families that are only
dependent on solar panel
energy, who also
have cell phones,
we saw go to their
friends' houses
to charge phones, which
gave us the idea of having
maybe a community charger,
community solar power--
yeah, some of
center where we can
invest in various
panels that does
have an inverter to maybe
charge these cell phones,
instead of them borrowing
their friends' grid electricity
and stuff like that.
Yeah.
I don't know if
there's anything else.
Oh, and these are some of
the homes we stayed in.
And we had a good time
staying with them,
and learned a lot just from
living their everyday routines
and stuff like that.
I think that's about it.
If anyone else has
anything to add--
AUDIENCE: Any questions?
Ideas, comments?
AUDIENCE: We have
a lot of projects.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So today you guys are
going to have to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: --work hard
to narrow them down.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Sorry for
going over time.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So hi, everyone.
We were working with ASAPROSAR
in Santa Ana, El Salvador.
And while we were there, we
worked on two main projects
just to show them and work
with them to demonstrate.
We did three charcoal
burns, and we
showed three
different communities
how to make corn
shellers for themselves--
so bringing down a project
that had already been done.
We're just going to run
through some of our pictures
from charcoal and
explain how that one.
So at first, they didn't
have an oil barrel
when we went down
there, so we had
to go to the cooperative
in one of the communities
and find an oil barrel, first
of all, and then find someone
to cut the holes for us.
So Miguel was kind enough
to drill our holes.
And then we brought it to
the community, and we just--
we did three
different communities
on three different days.
And all three communities
that we went to
were really eager to help.
They all wanted to
be a part of it.
This particular
guy right here was
part of a community that was
looking at charcoal more of--
as an economic goal, I guess.
They wanted to sell the
charcoal, as opposed
to using it, because they had
just acquired new stoves where
they were using wood that
were outside, so they're
better for ventilation.
So these are just some of
the pictures from that.
They were all really
excited about the charcoal.
But the first day, our
burn didn't go so well.
We learned that using pretty
wet sugar cane wasn't great.
They hadn't dried up very well,
and sugar cane to start with
was a lot more dense than
some of the material we
had used when we burned here.
And we just didn't let
it burn long enough.
But it was also good
for the community
to see that, if they didn't
let it burn long enough, then
they wouldn't get
good charcoal from it.
Did you want to add anything?
AUDIENCE: And another
thing we realized
is that, when-- the first day,
when we grated the yuca, we did
it in relatively bigger pieces,
so it was still pretty dry,
didn't release any
of, I guess, the juice
or whatever it has in it.
So when we ground it up,
it was still really dry,
and so when we added it to
the water to make the binder,
we had to use so
much yuca to get it
to have that right consistency.
The one yuca didn't make
a whole lot of binder,
so we learned to put it
in smaller pieces to make.
AUDIENCE: You can
see how thick it was.
This was the first day.
AUDIENCE: It's really thick.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's important to note
that, in all communities,
people were--
some people were somewhat
familiar with charcoal.
Sometimes they had no idea.
But it was really
nice that everybody--
I guess we kind
of expected that,
but everybody worked
with us, and they came up
with their own little ideas.
I guess the two tour guides--
not tour guides--
that's a bad word--
the two people helping
us from the organization,
from ASAPROSAR,
were very helpful,
and they got really into it.
And so for the last
one, we actually
asked them to do
the demonstration,
and we were checking in and
making sure everything's OK.
So that worked out
really well in terms
of involving the community
actually to keep doing this,
because they're going
to keep showing people
in different communities,
so it was important for us
to involve them a
lot in the process.
AUDIENCE: They
got it down really
fast, so by the third day,
when we let them run it, we--
it was all in Spanish and we
couldn't follow most of it,
so we would ask our translator,
Juan Carlos, who was working
with us, and one
of the two people
who was working
in the community--
we asked him, oh, did you
remember to tell them this?
He was like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, I got it.
I got it.
AUDIENCE: He was
such a help to us.
AUDIENCE: He was a total pro.
So it was really good.
It's really exciting
to know that they'll
have the know-how
and the confidence
to really accurately
tell more communities how
to make the charcoal.
AUDIENCE: This Is Elena.
She was one of the
other community partners
that we worked with.
She was really into the
motivational aspect of it,
so she'd always be
like, [SPANISH]..
You can do it.
She kept encouraging the
people in the community that--
who are a little
more nervous about it
or who are more depressed
about their living
conditions, that they
could keep moving forward.
So she was really excited
about the charcoal.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It was a lot of
fun that pretty much everyone
in the community was
really involved with it.
At least on the last
day, we really sat back
and didn't really
do anything, and let
Juan Carlos and Elena
take the reins--
at least with the instruction.
But still the entire time
the members of the community
were really doing everything,
and they jumped right in.
No one was really very hesitant.
And there was something a
little bit for everyone to do.
When we crushed up
the charcoal, there
were a lot of kids in
the area, so they just
went to town stomping
on the rice bags.
It was really a lot of fun.
The person that was-- drove
us to the [INAUDIBLE] what was
that--
AUDIENCE: Julio--
AUDIENCE: Julio-- one day
he sat there and just made
charcoal briquette after
charcoal briquette.
He was like, oh, look
at the ones I've made.
Everyone was really excited
about it, so that was nice.
AUDIENCE: So with
the corn shellers,
[INAUDIBLE] had gone down, and
some of the communities had
seen--
or had heard about
using cans that they
had to make the corn shellers.
So we had never
heard of that, but we
were trying to go with it.
And the first day
that we went out,
we had to experiment with
using pliers and the cans
that they had.
So this was one
of the communities
that-- they were just
playing around with it.
And it was almost good in
a way that we didn't really
know how to do it
ourselves perfectly,
because it allowed them to
experiment themselves with it.
They found the best ways
that they wanted to make it.
They're using little
6-ounce jalapeno cans.
So these are someone the
woman playing around with it.
And then we also
did show them how
to use the jig with the
sheet metal and the hammer.
One of the things that
we ran into, though,
was one of the communities
didn't have pliers,
so we had to show them how to do
the whole thing with a hammer.
And eventually,
by the third day,
we came up with this idea of
having a variable corn sheller.
So we didn't actually close
it, and we rounded the edges
so it was just like--
could hold it in your hand
and adjust it to the
size of the corn,
because the corn varied a lot
from different communities.
So that was really helpful, and
this girl was really into it.
AUDIENCE: It was nice
when we found the way
to do it without fully
attaching the ends so
that, since a lot of the
corn were different sizes,
you would see a lot of the
members of the community
use one corn shell
and try to shell it,
and it didn't work because
it wasn't the right size.
So they'd toss it out
and try another one.
And you could see it
was kind of frustrating.
Who wants a corn sheller
that doesn't actually work?
So once we figured
out how to do it
with just rounding
the edges so you could
just the-- how tightly
you gripped it made it
work for every single corncob.
It was a lot more exciting.
And when we first showed
it to them that day,
the lady tried it, and
promptly put it in her pocket,
and went around with
the rest of the day.
It was amazing.
AUDIENCE: The third community
we went to actually--
we went and toured
houses and looked
at stoves in between,
when we had first
showing them how to make them.
And we came back
a few hours later,
and they were still all
sitting there making them.
They had been doing
it for hours on end.
They loved it.
Now we're going to talk to you
about some potential projects
we came up with.
AUDIENCE: I guess,
as an introduction,
because our trip was--
we just went with it.
We really didn't know the exact
projects they were working on,
so we took a lot of notes.
And there's so many
different issues
that they're dealing
with, and a lot of them
are not energy-related, per se.
But we took notes on
all of them, and we'll--
I guess we can pass that
on to other D-Lab classes.
But we picked four
as the main projects
that we can focus
on in the class.
And I guess the main
ideas were lighting
optimization, ventilation, a
charcoal insert, and a rice
husking--
modifying a mill
to do rice husking.
How do we want to do this?
AUDIENCE: I can just--
AUDIENCE: Go ahead.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So one of the
big problems in El Salvador
is there's only 3%
forest right now.
They're running into a
lot of issues with people
using all the wood for cooking.
So although some of
the families wanted
to use the charcoal to
sell it and make money off
of it, other families
we're looking at it
as a fuel source for
themselves for cooking.
But one of the
problems with that
is that they were--
the ASAPROSAR team
was working with the communities
to build new stoves outside,
and those stoves weren't
optimal for charcoal.
This is a picture
of one of them.
If you can see, it
has the nice chimney,
so it ventilates really
well, and it's outside.
So it burns really
well with wood.
So we were thinking along
the lines of something
that we could insert into
one of these types of stoves
that would make it be
able to use charcoal.
A lot of the materials
that they have there--
we thought about
sheet metal, and we
thought about
different ways to make
a kind of fryer basket thing.
But sheet metal is too expensive
for their living means, so we--
for our project,
we were thinking
about something with the cans
that we had talked about they
use for corn shellers.
They can buy them in the
market, and they're--
they have food in them
when they come with them
so that they can use the food.
We were thinking about
potentially making the cans--
just forming it and weaving
it into some kind of charcoal
basket that we could
insert into these stoves
so they could cook with the
charcoal that they make.
AUDIENCE: Something important,
I guess, to add for all of these
was that I think all
three communities--
and I think one was a little
bit better than the other ones--
but they really didn't
have any resources.
We spoke to a lot of
the people, and it
seemed like most are women.
Most of them are not working.
So it was really difficult
to ask questions like, well,
can you afford buying
something, because most
of the time they don't
really have any money.
I guess the biggest
challenge is try
to find materials that
already exist, or maybe are
part of the trash.
And we spoke to people
trying to figure out,
what are the type of
things that they can find?
And I guess the cans
is one of the things--
also the chips bags.
Empty chips bags was
mentioned as something that--
it could be found near schools.
Plastic bottles, any
size of plastic bottles
can be used-- so
things like that.
We were trying to see if we can
somehow incorporate any of this
into the design so
that it's not really
something that you can go
buy, because they can't really
go buy it.
AUDIENCE: So you want to
talk about the [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I can do it.
So the second problem that
we identified as something we
could address was
rice dehusking.
Some of the communities
were starting
to experiment with integrating
rice into their diet,
as well as their
standard corn and beans
for additional
nutrients, or at least
having it as another source of--
to sell, potentially.
But currently, the problem
was, if the-- they could either
shell all of the
rice by hand, or they
could take it to a mill that
was about three hours away.
And they had to pay about
250 to get the bag dehusked,
and then they had to come back.
So it was a very long
and tedious process.
They [? spent ?]
well over their--
a couple days' salary
or work just doing this,
and it's really not very
economical, and it's very hard.
So they experimented
with the mill to grind--
that they used to use to
grind corn to dehusk the rice.
To make it softer,
they had-- some
of the communities had put
rubber in between the pieces
of the mill.
But they found
that the rubber was
turning the rice kernels
black, which is not good.
So we bought a couple
mills and experimented
with other materials, which
included a lighter color rubber
material and leather.
So it was more organic material
to place in between it.
And we tried that
Saturday before we left,
and we had a decent
amount of success with it.
There has to be some
more fine tuning,
obviously, and probably more--
to potentially find some
more optimal materials
to use as the barrier,
but from what we found,
it's definitely got
potential, and it
shouldn't be too hard
of a project to tackle.
AUDIENCE: And that's
something I think that's also
supported by ASAPROSAR.
They're supplying these
mills to some communities
so that they can use it
almost as a microeconomy
to make money.
AUDIENCE: The insert goes right
in between these two pieces.
They're both, I
guess, ridged, so they
grind against each
other, but when
you have something
in between, it
stops it from pulling
the rice totally apart.
AUDIENCE: For the
lighting, there
were a couple of
different issues.
One was electrical lighting
and one was day lighting.
For electrical lighting, some
communities-- some people
had lights inside.
Some had lights that worked
and some that didn't work,
so it was--
it varied.
The conditions varied.
However, the families
we asked about,
is the light bulb enough--
couple of families
said yeah for--
at night, they had
one room in a way,
and that it was sufficient
to light that room.
In terms of day lighting-- so
the houses were completely--
AUDIENCE: Very dark--
AUDIENCE: Very dark-- some of
the questions we asked is-- are
why are they so dark?
And is that more of-- it's
expensive, or do you need
more light?
And so most of them
are one or two rooms,
and they had one window,
the whole house was.
Sometimes they didn't
even have a window.
And we found out that there were
a couple of different issues.
One was money.
Because the houses were
made with adobe bricks,
in order to leave--
it seems simple that you just
leave an opening so that you
actually save on material.
However, for safety,
and also for hurricanes,
they have to close that opening.
And to close that opening,
if they use wood or metal,
it costs anywhere
around $25 per window,
whereas the bricks are $0.30.
So that's $30 versus $25--
is a big difference.
Another issue they
said was some of them
didn't actually want more light
because of privacy reasons.
Parents and kids sometimes
are in the same room,
so they were kind of joking
around, but they said,
we can't do anything because,
if you can see things--
kids are always aware of
what the parents are doing,
and the other way around.
So it was more of
a privacy issue.
However, day lighting
could be improved,
or it would be great if
they have more light for all
of the tasks they're working.
And some of the ideas
we had were, again,
using existing materials.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: We met a Peace
Corps person from Texas who
used this in his house, and he
said that the roof was leaking,
so he just put a plastic
bottle instead of one
of the roof tiles.
And that was actually, we
thought, a really great idea,
because plastic
bottles are available.
And if we can find a way to
maybe cut the bottle in half,
and try to mimic the
shape of the roof tiles,
and incorporate some plastic
bottles within the roof
so that stops the rain, but
allows light to come in,
that was one idea.
Another possibility was there
was a gap between the wall
in the roof with about
6 inches in most homes,
and even though that's
a lot more challenging,
we were trying to think of,
is there anything that we can
introduce some a surface that
can catch some of the light
from the outside and
bring it inside--
something like the chips bags,
which is kind of like aluminum
foil--
to redirect it?
However, that's challenging,
because the roofs--
or the ceilings were--
and walls were completely
black from the smoke
of the cooking inside, which,
I guess, leads to the last--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so I guess
the last project we were really
working on was the ventilation.
So like [INAUDIBLE]
said, a lot of the homes
still had the stoves
inside, and a lot of them
were simply the
three brick stoves.
They just stuck the wood under
it, and proceeded to cook.
And it essentially charred
the walls completely black.
A lot of it was covered in soot.
And with the financial problem
of trying to even incorporate
windows into the housing,
which-- so much more expensive,
that we really had a
difficult time trying
to think of ways to
improve the ventilation,
especially considering
the fact that a lot
of the members of the
community don't make money.
They just live off the
land that they have.
So the idea of buying materials
is pretty much impossible.
So one of the thoughts
we had, other than
improving the stove so that
they're more efficient,
trying to get them
to move outside--
which they have problems
with, since the stoves
they have right now
are not very efficient.
They have to make
sure they close off
the entire area
for wind and rain,
because they're already losing
efficiency just with the stoves
they're using.
So a lot of them wouldn't mind--
if they don't leave
the stove inside,
they build an entire new
room with a roof and a wall
outside of the
house to put their.
AUDIENCE: So this was the start
one of the outside kitchens
that they're making.
So they literally close
a section off with walls,
and then they're going to
probably put something over
for a roof.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So
essentially, they're
making an entire new room.
AUDIENCE: And that's
supported by ASAPROSAR.
What they're doing is trying to
find families who are in the--
have the most need in a way,
and they're supplying them
with sometimes materials.
They said that the way the
organization works is they
never actually do it for you.
They would get a
grant from somewhere
and actually make
the community do it.
But these stoves that they're
building outside, or kitchens,
are not for everybody in a way.
So there are only certain
families who get them,
so it's still a
really big issue of,
how do we deal with
the stoves inside?
AUDIENCE: So we thought, as
far as a makeshift smoke hood,
essentially, since there was
the gap in between the house
and the roof, we thought
that maybe we could make some
of hood out of the materials
that they already have--
maybe overused clothes, or even
the chip bags if there was some
way to sew them together, and
channel the smoke at least up
into the cracks of the house and
hopefully guide it a little bit
more outside of the
room that they have--
because essentially, they
are just one-room huts,
more or less, so they're--
with no windows and one doorway.
So there really isn't
anywhere for the smoke
to go if it's not-- if it
can't be better channeled out.
And since it is only one room,
you sleep there, you eat there,
you cook there, so it's-- the
ventilation is pretty bad.
And that's one of the things
we really want to work on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Ending on a more
positive note, though,
it was an amazing experience.
Like we said, all
the communities
were very encouraging,
and really wanted
to make these changes.
There wasn't anyone who
was just the woe is me,
too depressed to even
try to make the change.
So it was nice to know that
they were really into me
making these improvements.
AUDIENCE: Just to add, something
important was ASAPROSAR--
the way they work with these
communities is to help them,
but to also help the land.
So there was a really
big influence on,
how can we make some
of these improvements,
but not hurt the remaining
nature that we have?
So a lot of the other
issues that we encountered
were water, latrines--
how do they make
them without actually
contaminating the water?
So I guess part of
these challenges
is to figure out ways that
don't hurt nature any more
so than what is
already existing,
because that's one of the
biggest issues they're
dealing with there.
PROFESSOR: OK, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: OK, so
introduction-wise, we
were the group that
went with AsoFenix.
AsoFenix is a group that's
based out of Managua.
It works with a group called
Green Empowerment that's
based out of Portland
so it's really
quite a good collaboration.
But anyway, they
focus on bringing
potable water
systems, green energy
solutions to different towns.
But the really
cool thing is, when
they go to implement
these things, they bring
a lot of infrastructure
with them,
because oh, we're going to
install a water system-- well,
you're going to need an
energy source for your pump.
Well, you're going
to need a room
to get all your equipment there.
Well, everyone should
have a clean latrine
so it doesn't clean--
dirty the water system.
So they really do a
lot of compound work,
and that's why it was really
exciting to travel around
with some of their interns,
see what they do firsthand.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
we'll just run down.
We went down there with
four projects in mind,
and we are going to present
those four projects and where
we see further action
possibilities for each
of those projects are.
So we'll start with the
juice sealer, the bag sealer,
which was a project from
last year's class, which
seals a plastic bag for the--
so that they can preserve juice
that the women are working on
in the community.
So we went down-- and this
machine device runs off
of power from a 12-volt
battery, and we went down,
and since last year they
have installed and connected
a micro hydroplane to about half
the houses in the community.
So this house that we
were staying in actually
had 120 volts of
power coming out
of like a normal
outlet in the wall.
But they did not have
any more batteries
that were not dead, so we
tried multiple ways to get
that to work.
AUDIENCE: Clarification is
coming out of the wall was AC,
and the device had a solenoid
that did not like AC at all.
Therefore--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it
really didn't want 120 volts.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
there's that too.
AUDIENCE: So we tried reflecting
with a corrugated metal
piece of roofing
onto a solar panel,
but didn't have
enough current coming
out of that to run the device.
And then we also tried
charging a battery--
a car battery that they had from
before the micro hydroplane,
but that battery
was completely dead.
It charged from like
1.5 volts to like
1.9 volts in three hours.
So then we strung
up those batteries
that you saw in the
last picture here
to get it to work so we could
at least give a demonstration.
And that was some good
[? compo ?] engineering.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so we were
able to give a presentation,
and they were pretty
excited about being
able to seal the bags.
But leaving them a
string of batteries
on a stick taped together is not
something that's sustainable.
[LAUGHTER]
For this project, we
can further develop it
by making it so that it
can run off of the AC power
that they have.
And then we also
found out, after they
left, that some
houses that aren't
on the hydro electric grid
still have solar panels
and charged 12-volt
batteries, so bettering
the design for this project
to suit that-- because they
might-- depending on what
we hear back from AsoFenix,
they might have to take
out the air in the bag
so that the seal would have
to be a seal for the juice
airtight and no air in the
bag to completely preserve
the juice so that
they can sell it
after the peak orange
harvesting season, when there's
a market for orange juice.
So yeah, moving
on to [INAUDIBLE]..
Sorry, these aren't in order.
I though it was.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So another cool project
that got to go and see
was a biodigester.
Yes, this is the same
one that we went and saw
in a town called [INAUDIBLE].
It's hooked up to
the grid, right?
Yes.
Yeah, power has
come to [INAUDIBLE],,
but people still
cook on wood stoves.
And a great way
to supplement that
is with methane from
biodigesters like this one.
So this one belonged
to a household
where the woman cooked
twice a day on it.
But it would often run out.
She'd have really no idea how
much gas it was producing.
So one of the projects
we went down there with
was to make some of simple,
yet elegant meter for her
to tell just how much gas was in
a pressure meter, essentially.
Do we have a picture?
Yes.
OK, so our simple [? compo ?]
engineering solution was
to take a piece of clear
tubing we had brought,
mark off some in increments so
you could see whether or not
the gas coming in
from the tank--
which is the gray piece
of conduit there--
would press against the water.
So basically, you would read
where the water in the tube
meant the air, and it would
indicate if the pressure had
risen or fallen.
Yeah.
So it's also a pressure
release system,
which is really important
if the bag gets too--
you don't want
the bag to get too
over-filled with gas and the
pressure to get too high.
So basically, if the pressure
somehow got to the end of that
6 and 1/2 inches of tube--
which is highly unlikely,
since she uses it every day--
the gas would simply just
bubble up to the top.
However, there were
some difficulties
that we noticed, like with the
daily feeding this machine--
or this system, just
basic use of it.
We hopefully solved that
one with this simple meter.
But another one was just
it's a very messy task.
Basically, it's a whole 5-gallon
bucket of manure that has to be
mixed in a one-part manure,
three-part water mixture,
and then added, and
then poured through--
if we go back to the picture
of the entire system--
AUDIENCE: I think I might have--
AUDIENCE: --poured through
a relatively narrow pipe.
And it's just very
sloppy and messy.
It's-- also entails mixing
the manure and the water
in a bucket.
She had a little trowel
that she did it with.
[INAUDIBLE] and I got nice and
dirty giving it a try as well.
And yeah, it's just
a messy procedure.
If we could come up
with some of device
that would mix the
slurry in the bucket,
as well as aid in pouring
it, not only would it
make this a lot
easier to use and be
able to make her-- or help
her get her chores done much
faster, but it would
make biodigesters
less messy in general.
And I think that's--
imagine that would be
an applicable market
for biodigesters in the
states, biodigesters
in other developing countries.
It would be a very
transmutable project.
AUDIENCE: So one
of the things we
did a lot of thinking
about before we went down
was doing a washing machine.
So we had some extra
time [INAUDIBLE]
we were waiting
for the biodigester
to see if our levels
of gas was changing.
So we talked to
several of the women
and got them to show us how
they're washing clothes.
In this case, they're doing it
in a lavandera, big concrete
wash basin thing by our house.
But most of the women were
actually washing them down
by the river-- do
we have pictures--
on stones.
And you can't see it.
There was a well off the
side of that picture.
And we asked them a lot about--
so washing the clothes
by hand involved
a lot of vigorous scrubbing,
and also used a lot of water.
In this case, we were using
about that entire 2-gallon
bucket to wash one shirt.
She said that she used--
I believe it was about
30 gallons of water a day
for doing the washing,
and she did it every day.
She was only doing the
washing for three people,
because most of her kids
were grown up and not around
anymore-- so imagine that a
lot of families that are larger
would use even more water.
So we started asking
about what they
think about the task of
washing, and whether they would
like to use a machine or not.
It turns out that
there's actually
very mixed feelings about
the task of washing clothes.
Some women really don't like it.
Some enjoy it more
than other tasks,
and so would rather do that.
Some get bored and say
that it's something to do,
and so they enjoy
it for that reason.
And we asked them if they would
use a bicycle powered machine.
In general, they were--
we think they didn't
really understand
the concept of powering
a machine off a bicycle.
It was a very hilly area.
We didn't see a lot of
bicycles, especially
off the main roads
that were paved.
And might have been better if
we had had pictures of that
to show them the idea across,
but in general, the response
was they didn't know if it
worked, and if it worked,
if they liked it, they would use
it, but they couldn't say now.
Some specific things about
[INAUDIBLE] is that they have
a water--
potable water system, and
they pay money for it.
So there was a machine
up by the house.
They'll do their washing
still by the river.
So if there was a
machine up by the house--
houses that they
would have to use,
it would have to
use almost no water,
because they don't want
to pay for the water.
The well that was by
the river, which is--
which we first thought
might be a good place
to put a machine, was actually
built by a few families.
And they own it,
and other people
aren't supposed to use it.
And they own the
land that it's there,
so that would cause issues about
who could use the machine, who
it was for.
We considered a portable thing
that would be brought down
to the river, but there's
already a lot to carry down,
and it would have to be very
lightweight, and not bulky.
And then, in general,
there isn't things
that the women aren't
doing because they're
washing clothes.
It's not really taking time
that they would be spending
making money or anything.
And especially with the finances
in most households controlled
by the men, there
isn't much motivation
for them to spend
money on a machine
to make the task of
washing clothes easier.
In [INAUDIBLE],, we found that
there were a lot of obstacles,
and we didn't think
that it could really be
implemented successfully there.
So we moved on to
[? El Jocote, ?]
which was where we originally
imagined the project, and there
was a better situation.
They had one place by
the river that everyone
washed for the dry season.
There were already a
couple lavanderas there
that people would--
the women would use.
And there's often
multiple women there.
But again, it's only the dry
season that everyone's there.
Everyone spreads out along the
river during the wet season.
They're getting water
pumped to their houses
soon, so people are unsure about
whether they're going to be
washing up by their houses--
especially if they have to
pay money for it-- or down
by the river.
There's a main path that
goes right by the place
where they wash their clothes,
and animals-- lots of animals
can buy to drink
and stuff, so it
would need to be very
secure against the theft
and the animals.
We also heard that sometimes
the women will fight over
the best spots to wash
their clothes, which--
we would be afraid that a
machine that made it easier
might exacerbate that, unless
it worked so quickly that no one
minded the waiting time.
And then we had
the same concerns
about the possibility--
motivation
for fronting money
for a machine.
Water conservation was talked
about in both these cases,
but we were there
in the dry season,
and it didn't really
seem like they
were concerned about actually
running out of water.
So we're not sure that would
be a good motivation either.
So even though we did a lot of
thinking about this beforehand,
and the situation would
be slightly better
in [? El Jocote, ?] we
don't think that it's really
an appropriate
project to work on,
especially compared to
other projects we saw.
It seems to be more of
a solution in search
of a problem than something
that needed to be solved.
And if somebody really wanted
to work on a washing machine,
the best way to do
it would be to--
it could maybe be done
as a demonstration thing
that AsoFenix would have to give
people a better idea of what
we're talking about when
we say washing machines,
and bicycle powered,
and stuff, but it
would need to work
really well in order
to convince them that it was
something worth switching to.
So overall, we feel that a
lot of the other projects
are far more worthwhile,
and this probably
isn't something [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So our last project
was a millet thresher, which--
this is millet here on the
head, and this is the raw grain
after the processing.
So in the town of
[? El Jocote, ?] they--
most of the families
grow millet.
And the processing of this
plant takes a long time.
It takes a total--
so to harvest the fields, it
takes between four to six days
of one man working.
So they normally
have two men do it.
It takes between two and
three days to do that.
Then they wait 8 to 15
days for the heads to dry--
or for the stalks to dry.
And then they cut the heads
off of the stalks, which takes
another two to four man days.
And then the long,
time-consuming part
is knocking the
little pieces of grain
off of the head of the stock.
And the way they do this
is they have this device--
or platform here, where
they stand on that plank,
and then take the stick
and hit the heads.
And then the grain falls out,
because that's just pieces--
individual sticks going across
the bottom of the platform,
so the grains just fall
through onto the tarp.
Normally they'd have a bigger
tarp at the bottom of this,
but they just saved the
one bag, and their harvest
had ended before we got there.
But Jaime, the
director of AsoFenix,
requested that they
save a bag to show us,
so this is just one bag.
They would normally
have a bigger tarp.
And then there's a guy
below who's sweeping,
and that's because parts of
the head stock-- not the grain,
but the head stock--
also fall down.
And he's sweeping
those black bits
out of the pile of pure grain.
So normally in their
process, they'd
have two men on the
plank-- one man sweeping,
and then another man loading
more raw material up on top.
So it's a four-man
process, and it
takes anywhere between 4
and 10 days for each family
to process their
harvest, depending
on their size of
the field, depending
on the yield for that year.
So it's a lot of time, because
that's four men working
for 4 to 10 days.
So that's upwards of 40 man
days to complete this task.
The men don't like doing this
work, so there's a very easy--
if the machine works,
they will use it.
It's as simple as that.
Then, when you hit the
heads, dust is emitted,
and that stings your skin,
makes it really itchy.
And it's also not
very good to breathe.
And the man sweeping below
is just engulfed in this dust
during the entire process.
They don't necessarily
switch jobs that often,
so it could be one
man just sweeping.
So what they do
with this millet--
they cook with it.
They feed the leftover
heads and the mixed grain
that the guy sweeping out
the bits of black heads
to livestock.
Or they can also separate
it, because the--
in water, the grains sink,
and the parts of the stock
stay floating.
So let's see.
For this project, if--
it would be great to
have a machine that
gets like 80% of the
seeds, because this hitting
process doesn't get--
doesn't even get close to 100%
of the seeds out of this--
the head.
So if you were to
get 80% of the seeds,
that would be acceptable
for a machine,
especially given that--
their efficiency right now.
And then also, if you
had a way to control
the dust from expanding
off of the machine,
or if you could
keep it sequestered,
that would also increase
the health of the machine.
So that's it.
PROFESSOR: Thanks, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I have a question.
Is there a reason why
it's so high above?
Is it just literally
sticks, or is there
some sort of [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So it's literally
just sticks all the way around.
You can see the walls
better from here,
but the bottom is the same.
We thought the reason
that it's so high
is so that you can have a
man down there sweeping,
and if-- he's not hunched over.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: As it
falls down to the--
the dust that's with
it-- they don't really
want that to get in
the rest of the grain,
so when it's falling down,
the wind will blow it away,
so that gives more time for
that to happen too probably.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: There were
two in the community
that-- of [INAUDIBLE]
that we went to.
We only saw the one.
They have about 10 AsoFenix
that they've, I guess,
installed already,
and they're going
to continue installing more.
Only two of those 10
are operating right now,
successfully running.
And that was including the
one that we were working with
[INAUDIBLE], which--
we're not really sure
how much she's feeding it
and how much she's
actually using it.
So I don't know.
It's hard to say.
A big thing-- we're
not sure whether
it's because of
the mixing process,
that it just is unappealing to--
what is the logjam
that's creating
this gap between getting
the gas, using it or not?
So if it's that mixing, and we
can take the human element--
human handling out
of that process
if they would use it
every day, then that
would make a big difference.
But if there's another problem,
we'd have to address it more.